hey guys all right so this week new
Ghostbusters movie hasn't come out yet
so Doug isn't exactly sure what he needs
but what he does know is that he needs
the proton packs and the costumes for
the new Ghostbusters so I ordered the
costumes and they're in and so we're
gonna the doctor them up to make them
look more like the new costumes and they
need to build four proton packs from
scratch
so come on another workbench and let's
talk about
all right so as I said we know we got to
build the four prototype X and we need
the new updated costumes I couldn't find
the actual new costume like a Halloween
type costume yet because it's new
they're not being released until
September so I had an order the old one
that only come in male sizes basically
so I tried to get the smallest one I
could but the only one you can get is
standard size so I tried it on and it
fits me pretty good a little snug but
for the most part I guess I'm standard
and it doesn't really look much like the
new one
the new costume at all other than it's
got the logo on it I know it's got like
the orange stripes and stuff on it
and I'm not going to be wearing it
there's gonna be four women wearing the
costumes so they are probably gonna be a
little big on the actresses that we have
so that part we have to do and the other
thing obviously how the proton packs so
I got these images online so that's cool
I got some really good reference photos
and I'm gonna do my best to adhere to
the design so it looks pretty close but
I only have a few days to do it not a
ton of money and I have to build four of
them so I have a pile of junk of pieces
and stuff like that I'm gonna go through
and I'm gonna try and cobble something
together that looks pretty close to the
design and then once I have that I just
have to repeat it three more times so
yeah let's get cracking got a lot of
stuff to do
manney a lot of coffee let's go alright
so here's my pile of bits and pieces of
junk I've got a lot of pieces of PVC in
electrical boxes fittings little
containers yeah all kinds of junk tubing
and I try and cobble this together I
bought four backpacks and yeah let's try
and make something
all right so this is the basic gist this
is kind of based on the parts that I
have I think this is the closest we're
gonna get and it didn't take me long to
kind of put this together but I don't
think I have enough of these pieces I
have to get more of these boxes as I
think I'll add a few other odds and ends
and some wires and stuff like that I'd
like to actually make this light up if I
can but if I have time hopefully that
would be cool
I think if I could get that light up get
some kind of a red LED battery-powered
light or something that I could put in
there cool that didn't take too long so
yeah should be able to knock a couple of
these out
all right so as you can see it's kind of
finished legs up looks kind of cool yeah
I don't know if I'm gonna get a chance
to do all the little odds and ends I'd
like to do on it but for now I still
have to finish three or more of them so
yeah I think it looks pretty good with
the light up and it's light up kind of
thing as a few different features so
yeah I still have the costumes and stuff
like that to finish to you the jumpsuit
so
zero
all right so here are the four proton
packs completed I didn't really do all
that I would have liked to have done to
them but they need to get done it's
pretty late and I have a few other
things I have to do thanks to rob for
coming in and give me a hand he saw some
footage whenever he's helping to lose
some of the last few pieces on and help
me do some of the painting and stuff
like that the wands and stuff and
overall I think they turned out pretty
good oh yeah like I said I got a few
casting things to to take care of still
the costumes all the the jumpsuits are
done we just put the tape on and stuff
and yeah I think that's uh that's about
it for today it's about all I can do
physically and mentally so yeah be
interesting to see how things go in the
morning it's gonna be a long shoot it's
gonna be an early morning so yeah
so the shoot went really well I think
everybody was really happy with the way
they turned out the actresses were happy
Doug was happy and I think ultimately
they looked great on film so I'm very
pleased however I know that while I was
building I didn't go into a lot of
explanation as to what some of the parts
were that I used in the process I just
have a lot of footage of me building and
not a lot of explanation I guess so a
big part of that was he was just trying
to get him done as quickly as possible
most of the time I'm by myself too so I
just have the camera set up so I'm not
really thinking about it I'm just
thinking about what I'm doing
I'm just building and so but now I'm
going to go into a little bit of
explanation as to some of the parts that
I used and why I used them and so forth
most of it was out of necessity was the
other things that I had or I could get
easily or quickly because I had to make
four of the packs but one of the obvious
ones that most people spot right away or
whatever is the calendar as soon as I
saw the pack I knew that that's what I
was going to use so I went to the dollar
store and I bought four calendars I just
gave him a flat black paint with a
dusting kind of a light coat of a nickel
finish kind of metallic gray and they're
cheap enough plastic that when you turn
the light on inside they still
illuminate pretty brightly it kind of
shines right through I did drill some
extra holes and stuff like that along
the side so that the light kind of
peered through a little bit better the
light inside is actually the light
inside it actually is just an emergency
light and I think you can kind of see me
setting them up behind the scenes
whatever had some different settings
yeah
I was able to access that I had cut a
hole in the back so that I could press
the button and program so a lot of the
pieces that are lighter are just glued
to this EBA foam and the EBA foam is
mounted to some MDF board to give it
some rigidness so whatever reason and so
that I could screw some of the bigger
components or one zip ties and stuff
like that through it to attach things
like the calendar and stuff like that I
don't want to glue that on I knew if I
get bumped or something in my pop off or
even the light is a zip tied on things
like where the cable is gonna go over
and how the wand was gonna attach I
wanted to make sure that I could screw
that down and then this electrical box
which is one of the few items that has
some actual weight to it I wanted to
make sure that that I could screw on
also these blue boxes initially was
going to use a bunch of them for the
build but I only had three or four total
and I just wanted to get building as
quickly as possible and they weren't
quite the size that I wanted they're a
little bit big for the design and
everything so I remembered I had a bunch
of these foam blocks from a dollar store
buy a pack of like a pack of four or
something like that for a buck obviously
but yeah so I had a bunch of these
obviously super lightweight and I just
covered him with a metallic tape and
spray-painted them to give them a bit of
a burnished or kind of like worn look I
just gave them a light dusting of gray
or black rather kind of a flat black and
that kind of it still has a reflecting
like metallic quality but it looks
dirtied up and stuff so obviously things
like the PVC to replace the copper
tubing and everything and yeah this is a
piece of tubing with some duct tape and
electrical tape to make the kind of
emergency sort of sticker on there
things like the circuit board I just
have a bunch of circuit boards lying
around you know
things just glue it on there gave it
some texture and stuff
initially I wanted to add all kinds of
little piping and tubing and stuff on to
them but I just really didn't have the
time so just adding the circuit board
gave it some texture and you have things
like I think you'd see the yogurt
container so that just glued on there
and spray painted the whole thing is zip
tied to a backpack so that if I wanted
to I could reuse the backpack again and
stuff and yeah it's just a zip ties that
go through here I had a belt and kind of
strapped around their waist that's
basically it for the pack itself and
then the wand were pretty simple to him
it says PVC tubing and various sizes and
I drilled some holes to give it that
look initially I was going to have a
grip here so I didn't continue the holes
he's like the grip - I didn't I never
had an official grip I was gonna get
some grips to put on it just didn't do
it but this is just an electrical box
electrical connector box with PVC pipe
tin there this piece here is actually a
I think it's a half inch telescopic
coupler for PVC and then things like the
box there is this is a container cutting
it up but it's basically just a
container for like this one's for
tomatoes fruit and vegetable containers
whatever you get at the store I have
bins full of these that I'm saving for
another project
so again kept the weight down it has a
neat texture and once it's painted and
stuff like that you kind of blends right
in whatever so things like mounting the
the wands - the packs initially Doug
said he's like I don't think they're
gonna need to have them slung I don't
think they're gonna be any scenes where
I'm pulling him out if we do we can
always just cut to it like they'd
already have him there and they pull him
out and there was a few scenes but they
have to have them slung and so using
both hands and stuff like that so what I
want to doing
on set you can kind of see it in the
behind-the-scenes as I just added an
elbow with a couple pieces of PVC yeah I
just attached like that and then there's
a hole here for the other piece of just
slips on there like that and that kind
of held it in place so and it worked out
fine so cool yeah things like the the
jumpsuits I know I didn't go into a lot
of detail about that either Rob actually
came in and gave me a hand when we
basically was just the orange tape the
same orange tape that there's same horns
duct tape two strips of orange duct tape
with a thinner strip of white that I put
in the middle of each one and the reason
why I didn't use reflective is because
we were gonna be shooting on the green
screen and I didn't want it to possibly
reflect or in the lights and stuff like
that be too distracting on camera so I
just went with the white you know that
was kind of a quick thing was like last
minute I was like I have to do these
costumes so the orange duct tape and the
white duct tape took care of that and it
really only lasted the duration of
filming and they started to already kind
of fall off and stuff like that so if I
was gonna make a long-term one or if
you're gonna make a cosplay I wouldn't
recommend using duct tape I would use
some kind of fabric and stitch it on and
stuff like that so but that's about it
yeah again thanks so much for watching
yeah if you like these videos click like
tell your friends about it as long as
you guys keep watching them I'll keep
making them the next week's episode
actually is going to be a continuation
of the Mad Max series that I'm doing so
tune in for that and I'll see you next
time
thanks guys
you